foreign
Jade about a thousand people have sent
me this on social media and we've got to
cover it on today's show because it's
big news and not in a good way let me
read you the first line from this Fox
News article a Biden Administration rule
is set to take effect that will force
good credit home buyers to pay more for
their mortgages to subsidize loans to
higher risk Borrowers
this is wild yeah it says so let's break
this down there's a lot of that was a
lot of words yeah go ahead here's what's
happening people that have been quote
unquote responsible you know we don't
love credit scores here but people who
have good credit scores who are putting
15 to 20 percent down doing the right
thing are now being dinged and having to
pay more for their mortgages in order to
help those who have bad credit scores
and nothing down no
that's the summary no and this is not
spin like we can go political all day
because it is political but from a
financial perspective this is insane
purely yes my no is purely Financial by
the way
so here's the details experts believe
that borrowers with a credit score of
about 680 would pay around 40 bucks more
per month on a 400 000 mortgage under
rules from the federal Housing Finance
Agency which goes into effect May 1st
and by the way if you're thinking I'm
going to sneak under that no it's too
late you would have had to close two
days ago to not get hit by this it's
already happening it's just now official
official forty dollars more per month so
if you have like and We Don't Preach
30-year mortgages that's 15 grand 15
grand on top of your normal interest
that you're paying over the course of
your amortization schedule unbelievable
so the federal Housing Finance Agency
they oversee the federally backed home
mortgage companies like Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac you've heard about them and
they're they're trying to give consumers
more affordable housing options which
let me remind you uh the housing
Market's been struggling in the wait of
wake of all these multiple interest rate
increases by the fed and under new rules
consumer with these lower credit ratings
with less money for a down payment would
qualify for better mortgage terms than
they otherwise would have
I don't like this George so we're
awarding bad financial behavior to help
broke people become broker
and then hurting the people who have
gone I've done everything the right way
from the system right I've got the good
credit score I saved up my down payment
no you pay more now to help cover the
other guy this is this isn't what I'm
saying is not political but there you go
it's you're in this at this point we're
robbing from just normal middle class
folks who did the right thing it's not
even like robbing from the rich we're
just saying hey you've got what we need
can we we're just gonna take a little of
that when you're going to pay for this
so that more people can that that's not
right when the people who have done
everything right they're like hey I
saved my 20 you know I y'all know we
don't care nothing about a credit score
but if you're like I did everything
right I got my credit score up and now
here you are and you're having to to fit
the bill for this it's not right yes and
if you've seen the headlines they're
throwing percentages out there these are
not interest rate hikes let me make that
very clear this is something called llpa
loan level pricing adjustment and that's
part of the picture that then trickles
down to a affect the interest rate yeah
so that's what we're talking about here
and I'll give you some numbers so a
buyer with a 620 FICO score for example
or under 640 with a down payment of
three to five percent which is basically
nothing
they're going to see a 1.75 decrease
from the old rate of 3.5 for that
bracket right but if you've got a score
of 720 to 759 and you've got 15 to 20
down you get hit the hardest with a 0.75
increase from the old fee of 0.25 so
if you look at the chart it's a
beautiful kind of heat map that's out
there and that's what it shows the
numbers are very clear that those who
are awarded the most are those with
credit scores under 639 yeah who have
three to five percent down those who get
hit the hardest are those who have that
720 to 760 who have 15 to 20 and here's
the interesting thing if you've got way
more than that down
you have no effect
um and what's even more interesting
because I know the Ramsay fans out there
they're going oh my gosh I want to get
it home you don't have to worry if you
don't even worry because guess what This
only affects loans greater than 15 years
and if you've been listening to the show
for 15 seconds you know that we only
recommend 15-year fixed-rate
conventional loans that's it so you can
sleep at night if you're a Ramsay fan I
love that you can just sit back be a
spectator but can I just say I hate this
because I'm sure the intent behind this
is to level the playing field you know
to reduce that gap of folks who feel
like they're at a disadvantage to
purchase a home or have the opportunity
to purchase home but I'm like everything
every playing field doesn't have to get
leveled George sometimes you just gotta
work for what you have this is the
participation trophy it is and I get it
I'm not here to go hey if you're if
you're broke and you have a bad credit
score I never want you to be a homeowner
no that's not it I want you to be a
homeowner this isn't the way to do it is
to squeeze the middle class because
truthfully the upper class they're not
dealing with this even if they do have
mortgages their financial situations
their credit scores whatever it is uh
their their amount they have to put down
they're not affected by it it's the
middle class it's those people who I'm
trying to do everything by the book I
got my 15 20 and now you're paying 15
grand more over the course of that
30-year loan I love this part at the end
it says why was this done the answer is
simple it was to try to narrow the Gap
and access to credit especially for
minority home buyers who often have
lower down payments and lower credit
scores so let's just do what it imma
make somebody mad do what it takes to
get a to pay off your debt to increase
your income save your money so that you
can get a higher down payment there's
work to be done and stop acting like you
can't do that work and that you need to
wait over here for somebody to do to do
the work oh you got Jay preaching here's
the craziest part Jade this llpa
adjustment it helps make the government
more money uh of course it does what
else is new they're going we're not
gonna increase your tax this is we're
going to make our money another way by
squeezing the middle class a little more
I would like to squeeze them
listen I can't say it any better than
Jay just did this is insane and this is
the Ramsay show